they started the season as underdogs but
they've made it to the top of their game
[Applause]
the town players getting a hero's
homecoming after reaching the Premier
League for the first time in over 30
years the voice is gone as you can as
you can see and in here but yeah I mean
48 Hours has been a whirlwind
still quite hasn't sunk in yet
um
and I mean yeah we're just here to
celebrate this wonderful day with with
the town you know what we can do in um
we're gonna try to prove it next season
obviously we've got hard work to do over
the summer and um hopefully
[Music]
um we'll do well and uh we'll see what
happens this is a very rare moment you
don't get many moments like this in your
career so I think all we've got to do
now is enjoy it soak every bit of it up
[Music]
and the town was soaking it up too the
fans painting it orange and coming out
in force for a team which they say made
history
it feels like the whole town is out
celebrating people feel proud they feel
that their team was the underdog where
they came out on top and they have now
come out to say their thanks to them
for many here the wind was truly a dream
come true
[Music]
it's just a really proud moment for the
town
um you know Luton Town having struggles
and the teams had its struggles over the
years
um and yeah it's so nice to be here we
were at Wembley and it was just like you
know we were convincing ourselves
and it's that positive momentum that the
town now wants to build on hoping that
the team's success on the pitch will
mean better fortunes for everyone it's
jobs uh lots of opportunities for our
young people I'm a teacher and I want
them to have a bright future where they
can call loot in their home they will go
somewhere they want they come back to
Luton and stay here and you think this
one might help that as well absolutely
because instead of looking at all these
other big cities Luton will be their
home where they can build a future for
themselves
the future that we'll see lewton's
players facing off with the best of them
after three decades finally back in the
big time
Sky News